uh good evening members officers and
members of the public can I welcome you
to this uh planning meeting of the 18th
16th of November jump in my gun there uh
2022 as always
um
housekeeping
um I know our members are used to this
but general public are here as well so I
have to read this out if the fire alarm
is activated please vacate the offices
via the stairs and they are opposite the
lift if you use the lifts when you came
in tonight
either through the security door which
is to my right it's your left and of
course do not use the lifts opposite
um the stay away assembly in holy Square
opposite the offices and if it's safe to
come back in and obviously we'll say so
and bring you back
is there anybody intense filming this
meeting tonight
no thank you very much the use of mobile
phones I would ask that everyone present
please ensure their mobile phones aren't
turned to silent and they are not used
to make or receive phone calls in the
chamber whilst the meat is in meeting is
in progress
members requesting to speak under
Council procedure 20.1 I have councilor
Pugh under item for a
um public speaking again under four
agenda item four a Mr Tony Michael is
here thank you also item 4B and Mr Phil
Castle
Mr Castle you there
yes sorry thank you very much
uh agenda item one apologies for absence
I have apologies from
councilor Keane substituted this evening
by councilor Curry
also councilor shrub no I don't think he
has a substitute in tonight
no okay thank you agenda item two are
there any decorations of Interest
thank you members agenda item three
minutes of the planning committee held
on the 17th I think we
September
um
yeah yeah it's right it's all right so
I'm only reading what I've got down here
but it was the September meeting
um would members agree
sorry yes we're moving on yep 19th of
October on I'm looking at two columns
here so um
thank you I can't blame you tonight
Stephen uh minutes in the meeting of the
19th of October 2022
um could I have a propose that those
minutes are correct please several hands
going up thank you councilor Paul Moore
uh second to please councilor Crittenden
thank you all agree
thank you members
the um
now you've really lost me there Council
of heart
I think yes I think you're looking at
your
agenda which I I haven't got the I've
got my notes Here
okay but it would be October the minutes
of October yep
thank you agenda item four on the
schedule of planning
um items this evening if there are any
site visits they will be on the 2nd of
December which is a Friday
normally 9 30.
uh I'm gonna pass now to Mr Livingston
planning applications manager for a
point of information regarding item four
a thank you Ian thank you chairman good
evening members um on item 4A which is
the application for reclamat I just
wanted to correct an error in the report
on page 12 which refers in the other
matters section it states whilst the
site may be under investigation by the
environment agency this is a separate
match to the planning application so the
planning department doesn't have any
evidence that the environment agency are
investigating this was a reference to
the separate comments of Environmental
Protection within the council which
you'll see within the comments but the
primary Point that's raised in that is
that anything under other legislation is
entirely separate from the
considerations in the planning
application thank you chair
thank you Ian
so you've been on again to item four I.E
education for approval which is reclimit
limited wood Church Road birchington
I have the ward counselor
okay
okay I will go back on that again we
have the applicant with us this evening
I'll come to councilor Pew in a moment
uh the office person is Mr Tony Michael
if that's a correct name
you have three minutes to speak
thank you Mr chairman members thank you
for your time this evening uh the
officers have explained the merits of
this application very well in in their
report I only wish to remind that this
is a variation application and that
stacking of cards is already permitted
to four meters and has taken place for
12 years or so we only seek another 1.5
meters to stack vehicles to 5.5 meters
and this is the smaller part of the
overall site the rest of the site Which
is far larger cars are stacked up to
seven meters and have been so for the
last 20 years at least this is an
existing use and situation therefore and
established for many years and and there
is an existing mature established tree
screening which we'll be enhancing under
condition as agreed with the officers
reclamate a responsible company and
carry out a necessary role in the
community
and have been successfully trading since
1991 prior to this the site was Burke's
scrapyard established in 1960 so this is
60 years of such use as a scrap and
recycling facility recommet employs 50
or so key workers that are all local
people they have the KCC abandoned
vehicle contract and the KCC contract to
process their metal waste they are
contracted to Kent Police via the AAA to
collect damaged Vehicles they are
contracted to the Border Force to
process their seized concealment
Vehicles so they are not reused and they
Supply vehicles to the Border Force for
concealment training they are contracted
to Kent fire brigade to provide vehicles
for road traffic accident training where
they practice cutting off roofs to free
trapped passengers in cars they work for
direct line group AAA Insurance Tesco
underwriting plus 12 other insurers and
are part of a collection Network for
accident damage cars in Kent Sussex and
Southeast London they are audited and
accredited members of the vehicle
recycling Association the UK governing
body which accredits reputable vehicle
dismantlers as opposed to disruptible
ones who steal and sell parts of
recovered cars
they assist KCC with roadblocks to help
stop unlicensed scrap dealers and fly
tippers additionally recommend like to
try and give back to their Community
they donate cars to broadstairs college
for automotive repair courses to teach
students on they have donated many four
by four vehicles to the to the Ukraine
in the war against Russia
they recently transported a fire engine
from the Spitfire Memorial to Duxford
Air Museum free of charge they provided
lifting services on a Harrier aircraft
for the service personnel and Veterans
agency this is a government War veteran
Support Agency free of charge
they have donated over nine thousand
pounds to the rainbow Foundation a
charity that helps older people to
regain mental health and well-being
they paid for a helicopter to fly
veterans to the battles for victory show
at quex Park this year
repclement takes its role in the
community seriously and generously and
it does not cut Corners with that
responsibility thank you
thank you very much Mr Michael speaking
under Council procedure 20.1 raising
points of concern wall council at
councilor Pugh Council pew
thank you chair
um and thank you members of the
committee for allowing me to speak
um I called in this application because
I am concerned about the proposed
Heights for the stacking of vehicles in
these cars I appreciate the rec limit
have operated and have stacked cars to
this height for a number of years now
that doesn't necessarily in my opinion
mean that that is appropriate nor right
um
I've been concerned particularly about
the recommit site for a while mainly
from concerned residents but that is a
separate matter to this application now
I'm not here to argue that recliner
shouldn't be operating
um you've heard from the applicant or
somebody speaking on behalf of the
applicant that there are very
established business and they have been
there for a number of years I'm not here
to dispute that what I am here to
dispute is that
I don't necessarily think that
particularly in this current climate
when we're talking about the environment
and landscape and Views is it
appropriate for any business to be able
to stack materials to that height
particularly where it isn't actually
located in in a very open space now you
know the rec limit site itself is
situated partly on a bit of a slope
I've seen the stacking of the cars from
some distance they're noticeable from
manston Road quite considerably you can
see them from quite far away
particularly as you drive along the road
but I've visited the owners of Nelson
Park riding Center who are situated
behind the rec limit site away from
manston Road and even with the position
of the rectimate site being lower down
the slope the stacking of the cars is
quite considerable what it is already
now there has been mention of
and there may be within this uh this
condition these recommendations for
approval that there will be installing
of appropriate screening now what I
would urge the committee is if you are
minded to potentially approve
um this application is to for you to go
and have a site visit and take a look
for yourselves I'm sure the owners of
Nelson Park riding Center would be happy
for members of the committee to visit
and look from their angle
um because from what I see you know the
the amount of screening is minimal
around the site now there was some I
understand quite some years ago but over
the years they've been destroyed or I've
been told that there was a fire at one
point I'm not disputing that I'm not
entirely sure but my point is is that
there is minimal screening around the
site and even if some trees were to be
planted you would be able to see
particularly from Nelson Park riding
Center that you know there is a lack of
screening even if some screening was
planted it wouldn't really particularly
go in the way of of screening
effectively
stacked vehicles to this height
I do think it is a problem
um again as I said I'm not here to
dispute Rec limits right to operate
particularly in this site but I think
the impact on the landscape and the
surrounding area needs to be born
um quite considerable weight and from my
perspective and from what I've seen of
the site there is already a considerable
amount of cars stacking on that site and
I don't really think it's appropriate to
increase that and make that
uh make that worse
um but thank you for your time members
and I hope that you will either refuse
permission for this application or you
will agree to a site visit thank you
uh thank you very much councilor Pugh I
will ask you know Annabelle hemins the
planning officer to outline her report
please
yeah this is the application site as
usual outlined in red in this location
here
um the out the blue outline site which
is this office site here and The Wider
site is the recommend site and the
Nelson Park riding Center is in this
location here
and as has been mentioned planning
consent is sought to increase the height
that Vehicles can be
um stacked in this red lion area up to a
height of 5.5 meters
so this is an aerial view of the site so
the application site is this bit here as
you and you can see in the Nelson Park
riding Center which has been made
reference to in this location we have
woodchurch Road here and St Margaret's
Road in this location
um just some photographs of the site so
this is within the sites you can see the
cars stacked it
um
to uh took one above each other so with
two cars stacked so that's actually four
meters in height
so enough of you again you can see the
cars are stacked
um the forklifts that operate in this
part of the site and the vehicle
stacking
frames without cars obviously on them
so from the planning history set out in
the report members would have noted that
in 2010
and permission was allowed for vehicles
to be stacked to a maximum of height of
four meters and that was as we said two
cars High equivalent in the location
that we're looking at and this
application as I say seeks to increase
it to 5.5 meters
which is equivalent to
um free Vehicles stacked above each
other when you see your application was
originally submitted it was seeking
consent for maximum height of vehicle
storage for seven meters in height which
would be equivalent to essentially four
vehicles being stacked upon it on top of
each other officers raised concerns
about the potential issues particularly
a visual impact of those vehicles at
that height being stacked and so the
application has now been amended to the
maximum height 5.5 meters
and additional landscape opposed to site
boundaries so this is actually a view of
standing and looking for back at the
site from woodchurch road that is the
office building that we saw on the
location plan
and you can see there is some planting
here and if we look at another
photograph
further back you can see there are trees
along the boundaries there are some
difference in Heights of that planting
and as you can see here sorry let me
move my mouse there is some gaps where
you can see cars and vehicles stacked
but essentially along the boundaries
there is some Landscaping
foreign
excuse me so as we've seen there are
some gaps and the applicants are
proposing as I say to increase
Landscaping along these boundaries here
particularly to fill in the gaps and
essentially to provide planting of
mature conifers so Evergreen planting
and we there is a condition on the
applications
excuse me to secure deep further details
of that planting to ensure that it will
be um
Evergreen and it will be of a particular
size to secure
mitigation
as a temporary almost immediately
essentially it may not be to the full
height
um of seven meters which is what the
applicant seeks to achieve in the long
term but there would be temporary
mitigation
with the planting coming in it but
fairly mature levels
so with the reduction of height
from the seven meters so the four car
High to five meter 5.5 meters so
equivalent of three cars High
and the fact that Vehicles can be parked
and how are being stacked in this area
hatched here
up to seven meters in height so that is
in between the application site which is
here and the Nelson Park riding school
and other properties in this location
and the additional planting that's being
proposed offices are satisfied that the
application could um
go ahead with minimal impact on the
visual impact
um of the local area so the officer
recommendation is for approval thank you
chair uh thank you Annabelle
I move that the officer's recommendation
as you've heard is for approval because
the vice chair please second oh second
nature thank you councilman cook members
Council Albin
yeah thank you chair
um can I just ask the officer please
um
just to confirm that the riding stables
where they're facing the site
as I'm looking at that from the north
East
um
that there are cars up to seven meters
in height in where you've got the red
lines hatching
cars
right so what I was trying to establish
is is that the existing is that the
existing application which they've got
consent to put things up to seven meters
a night and therefore and therefore the
complainant is already looking at those
at seven minutes that would be correct
yes okay uh in that case uh chair I can
see no problem with this at all thank
you uh thank you councilor Alban do I
have any other members which counselor
wing
wedding Stables are is there existing
screening of trees there
and is that adequate do you feel that's
adequate to screen the present
height
um
I think there's sporadic Landscaping but
it's simply not a consideration for this
application because we're looking at the
variation of the 2010 which is only the
area to the south of of the regular site
if yeah if you can go back I understand
that but the complaint has come from
that side so it it might just be that
the uh that reclaim act will not only
Shield this side but also make some
efforts to Shield the other side to to
smooth the way uh like councilor Alban I
can't really see an issue there are some
gaps in the in in the in the uh in the
screening but as long as that happens I
I can't see this being a particular
problem I'd be more worried if it was
slap bang in the middle of a residential
area
and thank you for that counseling
cancer heart
thank you chair um I'm like-minded with
my colleague councilor Pugh because this
is in my ward and it is quite a
um
a visual impact as you go down the
manston road and I think if we start
getting them higher and higher I think
it's just going to destroy the view of
the countryside really and I think you
know they're high enough as they are I
don't necessarily see the need to just
go up to that height I think it's just
ah if if they have an issue don't stack
them so high you know don't have such a
gap between the cars I mean you know
just reduce it that way rather than
having a gap between I mean if you're
going to stack a third car on top my
car's more more than one and a half
meters tall so
um I can't quite see how stacking 3i is
going to be one and a half meters
um it's part of my question and secondly
I just think it is a visual impact and I
think that's just going to ruin the look
and and I think that's a shame really
because if you look for Manson all you
see is carts and get it even higher it's
just such a height it's high as a house
thank you for that councilor Council
bayford
thank you
chair I appreciate that he's a very good
business but
it it
by nature of the business itself is
going to be a little bit of an ISO and
rather noisy I do think for the benefit
of of those around and for the visual
impact it would be better to keep it at
the four meters thank you thank you
cancer every
well of course for the benefit of the
visual impact to be better if it wasn't
there at all but we have to consider the
thing in the round
um I think we'd be laughed at frankly if
we rejected this application because
there's absolutely no chance that we'd
be successful in defending an appeal
um and I should be voting to approve it
thank you
thank you uh councilor Owen bring you
back yeah thank you sir you know I
oh an Old Stage you're like yourself and
I used to use berkey's yard many many
years ago uh you're talking to me cancer
and I'm speaking on your behalf chair
um and uh you know it's always been
there you could always see it it's been
there it's there
the point is the complaint from the the
complainant is already looking at seven
meter high Vehicles so their complaint
that this is going to make it even work
is is
wrong because it's only going to five
meters so you know she can't see that
she can't see this part
anyway that's that's my storage here
thank you Council bayford
thank you Chuck I don't think we're only
looking at the um
the point of view of the riding school I
thought that's my from my point of view
it's for the whole visual impact of
everybody
um I I do think that three cars stacked
high is not a pleasant site
um I don't think that riding school
really they may have complained but I
don't think we should only be looking at
that thank you thank you councilman Taxi
thank you chair I'm inclined to agree
with councilor when they'll miss it in
fact whilst you've gotten going up
um that's how they said meters and
um
to that height of uh on the other side
then I don't see an issue on on going up
just one up meters on that side
you uh councilor Portmore yes thank you
chair I don't like to agree with Council
over it obviously but I do feel that if
this did go to appeal we wouldn't win it
um I think they are providing additional
screening from the roadside with which
is gonna
uh enclose that bit and as we've already
said they're going to five meters not
seven as they already are on one side so
it's going to be obscured by the seven
meters I think we've just got to protect
ourselves as well in wasting things that
will get past the appeal thank you
uh thank you um
Council hop
sorry chair um can I just ask just a
clarification Point
um four meters
is that the top of the car or is that
the racking height and then you have the
car on top is that five and a half
meters from Top from the top of the roof
to the ground or is that from the
racking point so effectively you'll get
up another two meters
so the the way the conditions have been
worded and this is from the 2010
application subsequently changed is
effectively that the height of the
vehicle stored shall not exceed
a top height of 5.5 in in terms of
what's there so nothing can go over 5.5
within that area basically
thank you right members I don't see any
other hand in the air so I'm going to
put this to the vote which is for
approval those in favor please show
those against
abstentions
thank you members that has been carried
thank you
foreign
keeping the mic thank you
okay thank you very much members uh okay
agenda item 4B which is Miles and bar 43
45 High Street broadstairs uh speaking
against the application is Mr castle and
I understand Mr Castle is there and you
have three minutes Mr Castle thank you
uh two applications were submitted and
granted during covid State home
restrictions so most people wouldn't see
the street notices planning confirmed to
me in writing we were not informed by
letter unlike our neighbors so there was
no coherent labor consultation on the
first two applications I would have
supported the first application but
would probably not have supported the
second application had I been made aware
and certainly not this retrospective
application nppf says any changes should
be sympathetic to the character and form
of the street scene and was emphasized
by a conservation officer in her email
of the 28th of July 2022 as an extract
here there was already a sense of
disparity of the proportionality of the
property however given how it has now
been constructed this is considerably
more obvious in my opinion as it has
stretched the whole scheme much higher
this has distorted somewhat the entire
elevation I would suggest that further
enforcement action is taken and the
scheme is implemented correctly this
email should be found in the red
perspective application but it in fact
is hidden in or recorded against the
second application as with the lack of
any photos of the site in the three
applications the error of admission is
convenient for the developer as it
doesn't give a full and true picture
photo 7 that I actually provided earlier
on this afternoon shows the sense of
overlooking and the enforced
subservience of the sub of the church
Tower from my home paragraph 130 of the
nppf states decisions should ensure that
developments are visually attractive as
a result of good architecture
sympathetic to the local character in
history policy SP 35 relates to the
quality and development states that new
development will be required to be of
high quality and inclusive design policy
qdo2 being the primary planning aim is
to promote or reinforce the local
character of the area and must be
designed as an integral part of new
development proposals and coordinated
with adjacent sites photos two and three
are supplied show the roof lines are
properties going down the High Street
included in the former NatWest Bank and
the Kent School of English and also the
um the uh the roof lining in Queens Road
all stepped down and this building did
even with the first two grants of
permission but the retrospective
application does not the church tower
has become a subservient to the
development it would not have been to
the initial application or as badly to
the second see photos one four and six
nppf policy section 16 paragraph 197
States in determining applications local
planning authorities should take account
of the desirability of new development
making a positive contribution to local
couch and distinctiveness the buildings
are not listed nor in the conservation
area but both could be considered
undesignated Heritage assets due to
their prominence at the corner of the
High Street and in Queens Road policy
he03 details the proposal to affect
non-designated Heritage assets will be
assessed by reference to the scale of
harm both Direct and into it or to loss
of significance of the Heritage asset as
a conservation officer said in their
email enforcement is needed enforcement
and implementation of the second granted
application should be the minimum action
taken by dtdc morally it should be to
the first grant implemented but with no
appeals process available I believe once
planning is granted even with a judicial
review unless evidence of fraudible
could be proven rather than the failure
of due process due to covert
restrictions which I believe is the case
here the second Grant will stand and
should be enforced
uh thank you very much Mr Castle
um
thank you
gave you a little bit of extra time
there moving to Annabelle once again to
give her a report on this application
thank you uh thank you chair
yeah this is the application site
outlined in Red so we have the High
Street running across the slide here and
this screens Road running downwards
um this is zooming in so
again we have the High Street here
Queens Road and this is the part of the
site we're actually going to be looking
at in detail
and so this is a view of the site as it
was from obviously from Google
um before the development took place
so you can see it did set set sorry step
down here in this location
uh this is a clearer image of it so
you've got the High Street there it
steps down down and then you've got a
single story element at that point here
and we have the church tower on the
right
um so this is um in 20 sorry in 2020
planning permission for the
for a first floor extension above that
single story element we saw a moment ago
was granted and the conversion of this
part of the building
um was allowed for Resident to to
residential
and in 2021 it was granted for a second
floor extension for an additional flat
this was what was actually approved
um in 2021
sorry and this is sorry that's to see
elevation that was approved in 2020
sorry apologies members uh so you can
see the first floor extension there
and that was what was actually approved
in the 2021 application
so that's the single uh second floor
element there
this is what has actually been built
so you can see
it is actually flush with the adjoining
um part of the building there
and so that's the elevation as it's been
built
um this is what is now being proposed
um with two members that is acting
actual detailing to the elevation to
make it more sympathetic and to blend it
in and tie it into the existing building
so I will go through some more detailing
about what's being proposed as we go
further on
but they are as you can see they are not
proposing to lower the height of the
building it is detailing to it
so this is just a view
of it as it's been built out you can
still see the Tower of the church and
the separation that does exist between
the two
um just looking that's a side elevation
that was approved this is a side
Innovation is built
and this is the rear elevation as
approved
and as built as you can see in both
those scenarios obviously it increases
in height but it is essentially very
similar to what's being built apart from
the front elevation but going back to
the front elevation as has been said
the applicants are now looking to make
detailed changes to this elevation to
tie it in and bring it
um some context to the surrounding
develop and break up the massive
brickwork so things like the string
courses are being put in so they'll be
rendered and
match as much as far as possible or
although there'll be some discrepancies
in height but it will tie in with the
detailing on the existing building
there'll also be window detailing so
lentils will be added and seal detailing
or added as well which would match those
on the existing building
and it really just seeks to try and
bring it together as a whole
and
essentially officers feel
that it these enhancements will actually
tie that building and bring it into
um
officially attractive manner that does
tie it into the surrounding area and as
it has been mentioned is they are not
listed buildings and they are not within
the conservation area and whilst it is
disappointing that
um the
approved development wasn't built out as
it should have been it is considered
these works are sufficient to overcome
officers concerns
um so the officer recommendation at this
time is to defer and delegate because we
are awaiting the payment of the required
Sam contribution for the application
thank you chair uh thank you I moved the
officer's recommendation is adopted to
the vice chair please second or second
nature I think it costs a common cook
members
councilor Auburn
[Music]
I beg your pardon councilman pull more
big partner thank you Council and thank
you chair uh chair at what point does uh
the case officer not real or realize
that this building is built beyond what
has been passed would be my first
question have we allowed it to get to
that stage why was it not stopped
because planning was only for a certain
height and now we've built this building
in line with everything else and quite
frankly if we say oh well it's a shame
they've done it but if they make it look
a bit prettier we'll accept it does that
not set a precedence for everyone else
to think they can do the same this is
totally unacceptable and I think that
the building firm that done it if they
can't read plans properly and measure up
right correctly that's their fault and
the owner knowing full well that it
wasn't to go to the full life as as
chance his arm and created this
monstrosity it impacts on the street
scene yes it's not conservation I
appreciate but it impacts on the street
scene it looks hideous and I will not be
supporting this application
thank you Council Moore councilor Auburn
yes thank you chair
um I have to say the photo that was that
was that was shown
he's he's that that's if you can go back
to the photo please
yeah uh obviously that is not what they
want
to do they want to add to that I mean as
looking at that is pretty brutal as far
as I can see
um the previously approved application
fitted in there very well looked very
good and I thought that was that was an
an excellent uh approved application
that whatever
uh the the owner of the property has
decided and to do that
um God Only Knows
um I think what's disappointing if we
can go back to the the last plan that
you add up last elevation you add up
thank you obviously I'm taking uh what
looks like a a lintel going going across
the whole of the set of the first floor
top Windows there
um if that if that was raised up if that
was raised up it's obviously because
that was the roof that was the the
height of the previous
roof I take it to be
um I actually go along with uh councilor
more as though I don't really go along
with him much but I'll just get my own
bet for my colleague
um
we can't you know basically two answer
Council Moore's point you know every
application is dealt with on its Merit
and it doesn't set a precedent
per se
um of course other people might decide
oh they've done it and I'll get away
with it
um but all applications are different
but I actually think it does look a bit
brutal on the on on the street scene and
for me I can't support this chair thank
you uh thank you Council hold on before
I come into cancer every so Ian
um thank you chair um just to come back
on the the point with regards to
um
you know discovery of the fact that
they've built the eaves height there's
obviously it's the main thing that the
roof doesn't step down the eaves height
is is not lower as obviously designed
um fundamentally it's it's all about
when we find out which is when the
scaffolding comes down and we've got the
complaint in you know that's when it's
investigated obviously in terms of
stopping it obviously when the
scaffolding comes down is when the first
time you see it in terms of a stop
notice
um
we wouldn't be able to server stop
notice on this it's not a list of
building
um we're be liable for compensation it's
just not it's not the way unfortunately
the planning enforcement system's set up
but I absolutely agree with the the
sentiments here what obviously we have
looked at is the proposal has been put
in on the basis of what's been built we
made it clear at the enforcement stage
that wasn't going to be acceptable
because as you've seen the photo I mean
you know they don't need to really
elaborate on that
what's been proposed obviously is to is
to alter the the design around the
windows and adding the string course
again to try and soften the what you
refer to as the solid to void ratio to
so and so on the brickwork but the
fundamental question
is not so much about I suppose the the
features on there is that is the drop of
the eaves height so fundamental that it
now means that the proposal is
unacceptable and and that's has to then
take account of the other elements that
they're putting in to try and alleviate
the amount of brickwork so that's the
main question for members is does the
fact that the eaves does not drop down
now make it unacceptable and again as
has already been outlined it is as
Auburn said on the merits of this
proposal
um irrelevant that it's there obviously
you can see it so that helps but the
judgment is is it acceptable or not even
though it's there
uh thank you Ian cancer every
um let me answer your question then Mr
Livingston it's not acceptable as far as
I'm concerned
um but I was quite shocked by that
photograph actually I think it's quite
Stark and whilst I uh I recognized that
some mitigation is proposed
um I don't think it's sufficient to um
to mitigate the effects of that building
being built to the same height as the as
the adjacent part of the building so
um clearly we're not here to punish
people for breaching for for going
outside the the permission that's
granted that's not our job as a
committee but equally we're not here to
be sympathetic to them because if we
don't accept what they now propose it
might cost them money to take it down
that's their problem they built it
um my feeling is that it that that is
significant enough for us to refuse this
application and I think the the impact
on the street scene and the setting of
the church is sufficient to justify a
refusal vote against it thank you uh
thank you Council right
thank you chairman um I'm a little bit
miffed as to how they think that that is
balances up
to what's all what was in the original
plan I mean to my mind if it
I I
Pat over there knows that how I feel
about retrospective
applications and when builders get it
wrong but this to say that this is
acceptable and acceptable compromise if
the windows were light for light for the
existing one and maybe with the other
windows around the side to break up the
starkness but I agree with everybody
else that in its present form it's not
acceptable
thank you thank you Council scripture
thank you
um there were two images that I would
actually quite like to see again
um one is of the street scene with the
um building and the church and the
diagrams of the original plans that were
proposed
um
yeah I think that was it
um I do think that the proposed
amendment I artistic interpretation is a
matter of opinion but I actually think
it looks even more of a pixie than it
does now if I'm allowed to use such a
phrase
um
it has become very dominating and very
brutal and so I'm just wondering can we
can I also have a look at the original
yeah it's all higgledy pickledy
I guess that's not going to be corrected
but
that the plan you wanted that's the yeah
I mean that's fairly brutal but thank
you
councilor Beaufort
thank you chair I mean it might be the
way we should be looking at this is
would we have accepted this proposal
to start with and for me the answer is
no it's a stark and it doesn't
it doesn't fit with the street scene
so I personally think that we should
refuse it thank you thank you Council
Ghana
thank you a risk of joining a um a
piling on this
um
I would like to use a phrase used by
Council of Everett at the last planning
committee meeting when we were when we
were talking about the fair lines Fair
Lawns Road and I was a bit reticent of
using it myself but he was correct that
They're Taking Liberties they have been
um this isn't a mistake they've done it
on purpose they've thought that they
would get one over on us and and I don't
think we should bear in mind and and
bearing in mind what you said about you
know looking at this on its own Merit
I agree with councilor Byford if that
had come before us uh to but to consider
before they'd built it then it it looks
a dog's dinner to me and I wouldn't have
approved that
thank you counselor
they share I must agree with my fellow
colleagues here at least with the first
one where the roof dropped
um that banding went all the way around
um and as it is now that you have that
drop in that band that goes around the
middle it makes it look even worse
um I am in agreement with all of them I
I think that this is a liberty that's
been taken by the Builder assuming that
we would just agree retrospectively
their permission we wouldn't have agreed
this in the first place it looked better
with a drop roof and unfortunately I as
far as I'm concerned it should look like
the original plans and that's it and
because even with that banding like that
it just looks odd absolutely odd but if
the when the roof was dropped it went
all the way around and looked
sympathetic but as it is it just looks
really
really awful really awful thank you
thank you counseling
and keeps going here and because I I
just I was very confused about what
they'd actually been given permission
for because we seemed to move away from
the fact that they've almost added a
height to sort of concentrating on the
little knickknacks that they've slapped
on the front of the property in the hope
we won't notice and I think they've done
that badly it's almost like you know
having a football team and we've got one
player with the wrong color shirt and
the wrong color socks on in the hope we
won't notice but it just sticks out and
I think well I think the very nature
that it stepped down sort of kept some
of the historical element of the street
while also provided the developer with
the means to slightly develop the
property and we're not looking at some
individual person who might have got
this wrong this is Miles and Barr they
clearly understand
planning processes so I'm agreed that
that you know this we wouldn't approve
because it just looks hideous uh even
with the little knickknacks on the front
uh and we would have made approved the
other one which would have stayed in
keeping with some of the the heritage of
the street a street which is a very
prominent Street in broadstairs so I'm
gonna vote against I'm afraid
I think counseloring
no I'm Mr Castle I'm afraid you can't
rules don't allow aren't you spoken I
can't uh please
I can't allow you to if you don't mind
thank you Miss Lewis so I just want to
come back on something counseling said
the applicant isn't miles and bar the
building is is the miles and bar
building it's the former spice and
McCool building as well just just to
confirm the applicant isn't Martin bar
thank you for that um I don't see any
other speakers uh so I'm going to put
this to you members which is to defer
and Delegate for approval those in favor
those against
abstentions
write that proposal has been lost so
um if I hand over to Mr Livingston
thank you chair
um so just to run through I've obviously
been listening to the debate and
obviously been putting something
together with regards to the points that
members have raised
um and in terms of
uh looking to refuse the application uh
there are there are two reasons one is
the primary reason of the design which
I'll go through in a second the second
is a technical reason obviously the
reason it's deferred is to make sure a
contribution is secured because it's
additional residential accommodation
which needs mitigation to avoid impact
on the special protection area so
there'll be a technical reason for
refusal which relates the fact that the
mitigation has not been secured but the
primary reason would be I think the
proposed development by virtue of its
height design and relationship with the
adjacent Church would appear cramped
contrived and in Congress within the
street scene failing to respect and
enhance the character of the area
contrary to standard local plan policy
qdo2 broadstairs and St Peter's neighbor
plan policy
bsp-9 and paragraphs 130 and 135 of the
mppf and that would be my recommendation
if a member wanted to move that
thank you before I do that councilor
Auburn councilor Pat Moore
did you vote on
that item because their Clark didn't see
you just for the record
against
thank you thank you for that just for
just for the record right thank you
Council Auburn
exactly what uh Mr Liberty started said
I'll propose that chair I couldn't
remember all of the wording on that but
I proposed at you
I'll bring back in in just a second just
to confirm it's two reasons I outlined
the the design reason in terms of the
impact on the character of the area but
it's also the um the the Sam reason as
well
thank you so I need a second for that
and do you all agree agree chair any
against no that's fine thank you yep
that's fine thank you that uh members
brings us to a close I'm going to ask
um Stephen to cut us off because we've
been live but um you're not going to get
away as easy as that tonight because uh
Ian wants to have a quick word
thank you
it could be a Christmas tree
um so it's just to confirm obviously
this agenda was was slightly smaller
than we were anticipating obviously we
do look to try and make sure the
planning committee agenda has sort of
about five items on to try and get
through the the amount that we've got
going to committee but